ça va ça va et toi tu vas bien et to
comment tu vas ça va mon frérot tu aimes
bien le le décor génial je retrouve des
des fragments de toute mon année passée
c'est littéralement des flashback wou
c'est un saut dans le temps c'est
exceptionnel mais non le P c'est ouf on
a tout tout
ramené bien frère et là ah on est devant
ah c'est oh il a même la
table la galère je te raconte pas la
galère pour ramener cette table cette
table ici c'est littéralement ton bureau
qu'on a orté ici quoi on est obligé de
dire aux gens que qu'on est très am on
peut pas faire gen bjour monsieur
[__] mer je su cont de faire
votrems on est très ça fait bizarre du
coup de faire uneie écoute je me fait
interv par un de mes meilleurs potes
c'est exceptionnel vasy on peut poser si
tu veux ah moi j'allais m'assoir là la
déformation à côté du bouton ouais le
fameux évidemment qui évidemment est
relié à cette télé télétable c'est une
télétable exactement c'est le premier
concept mondial de la télétable importé
dans Hugo des GP bonjour Lucas bonjour
Squeezie bonjour Hugo comment je
t'appelle Lucas ou Squeezie euh comme tu
préfères ce sera Squeezie ça me va très
bien parce que c'est la façon les gens
connaissent mais je pense que je dirai
Lucas sans faire exprès plusieurs fois
pendant évidemment très
bien attends mais faut dire que c'est un
très gros exercice pour toi là c'est
compliqué parce que dans ses interviews
il est plutôt genre classe présentateur
mystérieux et tout et cut là il a envie
d'être lui-ême le vrai ho celui que je
tabasse à Mario Kart et qui rage et du
coup voilà
regardez là sur l'interview aujourd'hui
je pense que tu connais le principe je
te l'explique quand même j'en ai vu
quelquesunes il y a cette télétable du
coup face face à nous ce nom va rester
un objet très étrange une télétable une
marque déposée une roue de symbole va
s'afficher à l'écran je vais te laisser
appuyer sur le buzzer cont tu veux ça va
arrêter cette roue sur un symbole et à
chaque fois c'est le point de départ
vers question ah tout de suite
directappu quand tu
veux ah c'est une discussion sur M V
d'entrée de jeu directement ce sera pas
ça c'est en l'occurrence une personne on
va dire relativement âgée on va dire un
sage on va dire ça comme ça un senior
c'est un terme qui s'utilise sans
problème pourquoi et ben parce que tu as
beau avoir plus 18 millions d'abonnés
sur youtube il y a toute une partie de
la population qui te connaît peu voire
pas du tout et donc on a quelques
personnes qui vont venir tout de suite
hein parce que ils ont des questions
bonjour à vous poser bonjour bonjour
comment allez-vous ça va et bah ça va
super merci d'être là mais c'est super
ça Michel merci d'être là Jean Jano ah
Jano ah oui Jan absolument l'appeler Jan
ok Michel Jan et Raymond oui
merci à tous les trois d'être d'être
présents vous avez respectivement 74 ans
81 ans et 88 ans voilà vous avez des
petits enfants en général qui
connaissent forcément Lucas qui
connaissent Squeezie plutôt d'ailleurs
mais vous vous avez des questions
bonjour je sais pas si je dois vous
appeler monsieur Squeezie ou Lucas c'est
comme vous voulez comme vous préférez
Lucas je pense là on est entre j'aime
bien Lucas donc Lucas je dois vous
avouer que il y a 8 jours j'avais jamais
jamais jamais entendu parler de vous
est-ce que vous voulez bien m'expliquer
qui vous êtes ce que vous faites et
comment vous êtes parvenu à cette
renommée incroyable et ben je fais des
vidéos sur YouTube une plateforme de
vidéos sur Internet c'est quand même je
reprends tout du début je sais pas
où'arrête là je sais pas où est votre
niveau de connaissance mais et ben voilà
bah quand la plateforme est apparu en
France enfin est apparu quand elle a
commencé à devenir populaire c'est ce
qui devait être autour de de 2010 2011
en France bah j'ai commencé à faire des
vidéos sur la plateforme euh des vidéos
qui tournaient autour des jeux vidéos
c'est-à-dire alors c'est un un principe
qui peut vous paraître très abstrait où
en fait j'enregistrais mes parties de
jeux vidéo et je parlais par-dessus
voilà d'accord Jano est-ce que vous
aviez une question moi j'ai une question
à vous poser ça fait peur oui oui elle
est bavarde hein pas ça va régler ses
ils viennent de se rencontrer tous les
trois ah ouais ah vous venez de vous
rencontrer là d' vient ce nom Squeezie
ah euh pourquoi tu t'es pas appelé jeano
ou
j'auris ex ça aurait plus non Squeezie
c'est parce que bah j'étais très jeune
au moment où je commence cette chaîne
Youtube j'écoutis une musique en réalité
à ce moment-là qui s'appelait squeeze it
c'était le titre de la musique squeeze
it qui veut dire pressle ça sonne bien
je remixe un peu Squeezie allez hop
Squeezie voilà moi je vais laisser
tomber Youtube pour un moment OK et je
vais vous parler de fortbyard ouais
vous y étiez en 2017 ouais est-ce que
cette émission d'abord vous a ravi et
est-ce que cette émission a donné
beaucoup plus de
notoriété après honnêtement oui ça m'a
ravi c'était assez extraordinaire parce
que en réalité c'est très proche de ce
que des jeux que nous on fait
aujourd'hui sur Internet Fort Boyard
c'est même moi une de mes références sur
pas mal de de plans ensuite est-ce que
ça m'a apporter euh je sais pas c'est
une bonne question c'est une bonne
question je m'étais jamais posé cette
question peut-être en fin de compte je
sais pas moi je voulais te demander
est-ce que tu vas à la pêche à la pêche
à la pêche à la ligne j'ai jamais fait
de pêche à la ligne est-ce que tu
bricoles à la maison pas du tout je suis
pas du tout BRI plus alors que moi j'en
fais hein ah ouais ça bricole je vais à
la pêche et je bricole bricoler et
pêcher ah oui j'aimerais bien en arriver
là un jour clairement pas tout de suite
pas tout de suite parce que je suis je
pars de trop loin je suis vraiment nul
avec mes mains je suis pas manuel du
tout ah bon non je suis pas manuel du
tout c'est
dommage je pense la même chose c'est
dommage Jano je crois que vous aviez une
dernière question que j'ai trouvé et
drôle et intéressante concernant quelque
chose que vous avez vu sur la chaîne
Youtube de de Squeezie je vous laisse en
parler qu'est-ce que c'est je voulais te
demander ouais comment comment se
fait-il que tu fais des gros yeux comme
ça sur la
photo tu es alors c'est c'est pas des
vraies expressions de du visage je je
ils sont pas beau hein ils font un peu
peur même ah ou il font peur il est
mieux en vrai je je retouche la FA pour
honteusement attirer des gens sur ma
vidéo Jan c'est ça la vérité d'accord
mon Petitfils m'a passé un article
interview que tu avais donné au monde
ouais et dans il y a une phrase que je
voudrais que tu m'expliques tu dis ma
passion mon fil conducteur c'est de
créer du
contenu tu as dit ça ouais alors c'est
ça veut dire quoi créer du contenu oui
le contenu c'est la c'est la vidéo en
soit on appelle ça une vidéo on appelle
ça un contenu nous on se définit souvent
comme créateur de
contenu on peut dire youtubeur certains
des influenceurs aussi n on l'utilise
quand même très RAR mais le terme de
créateur de contenu bah c'est ça parce
qu'on crée des choses mais parfois c'est
des vidéos parfois c'est des c'est
tellement de choses varié qu'on regroupe
tout sous le mot contenu d'accord je
connaissais pas in
inimcoup merci beaucoup Merci à VOUS
mercinorémenté super intéressant vous la
voulez la
photo
merci à tous les trois merci beaucoup
merci d'être venu merci beaucoup
merci c'était intéressant ça tu as vu ah
c'était super intéressant tu penses
qu'un jour on sera dans le même décalage
avec la plus jeune génération
possiblement je pense aussi que quand tu
es quand tu es jeune aussi tu es tu es
vraiment dans ce truc de recherche de
nouveauté de ce qui se fait de tu vois
tu es tu es au taquet je pense que quand
tu quand tu te mets à à mûir et avoir
des enfants et puis des petits enfants
je pense que tu en as plus rien à [__]
en vrai ta priorité ça devient plus
prendre soin de tes enfantses petits
enfants ce serait pas bizarre en fin de
compte que nos grands-parents ils soient
hyper à cheval sur le truc qui
comprennent tout bizar ça F un peu
flipper quand Mme combien ton t de CLI
sur minature watch il est est on sera un
peu choqué quoi et au passage là je
réalise qu'on parle beaucoup de YouTube
parce que on a commencé en général sur
Youtube pour chacun d'entre nous mais en
réalité on fait tous aujourd'hui des
contenus sur toutes les plateformes tous
les réseaux sociaux TikTok Instagram
twitch il y a pas que youtube il y a
plein d'autres non c'est vrai ouais bien
sûr c'est mais on a commencé avec mais
dou le terme d'ailleurs créateur de
contenu qu'on utilise plus que youtubeur
en général aujourd'hui parce qu'en fait
c'est tellement large et oua c'est vra
çaass sur plein de plein de choses on
relance la Rouette va
quand tu
veux ça va s'arrêter sur un bébé ou un
enfant en tout cas ok c'est un pe en va
voir ce qui se cache juste derrière me
voilà enfin vous me voyez euh pourquoi
pourquoi je fais cette vidéo ben tout
simplement parce que je suis un peu je
suis je sens un peu gêné là quand même
première fois que je me monte vraiment
bah tout simplement parce que ma vidéo
sur Dead Space 2 j'ai pas pu la sortir
dans les temps alors que c'était la
vidéo spéciale 200 abonnés et qu'on est
presque à 300 abonnés tu étais déjà en
retard j'étais déjà en retard sur tout
ce que je faisais dès le début c'était
il y a 12 ans quand même en 2011 donc à
l'époque tu avais 300
abonnés ça te fait quoi déjà de voir
cette vidéo ça me fait marrer je crois
ça me fait marrer en fait ça me fait
marrer parce que je trouve ça mignon tu
vois de de voir c'est un gamin de 15 ans
qui parle à des gens virtuellement ils
ont une passion en commun c'est les jeux
vidéos mais là on voit aussi en même
temps que ton côté une forme de gêne à
se dire j'apparais à l'écran pour la
première fois je montre ma tête c'est un
truc que tu et encore à l'époque je
trouve que c'était moins tu comprenais
moins ouais l'ampleur que ça pouvait
prendre ou l'impact de te montrer comme
ça sur internet pour moi cétait presque
un jeu quoi tu te souviens avec quoi tu
filmais ou pas bah au début on se filme
à la webcam puis ensuite je volais le
petit appareil photo numérique de ma
mère et puis ensuite mon père il m'a
offert ma ma première caméra HD qui
était oh comment tu as fait oh c'est
trop fort et tu sais que c'est ma
relique là tu as ma relique entre les
mains que je vois l'écran il a il est il
non mais c'est
littéralement il y a ça qui s'ouvre un
peu trop c'est pas le tu as retrouvé le
modèle quelque part c'est le vrai que
j'ai chez moi c'est littéralement la
tienne je le tiens comme si c'était ton
c'est sacré pour moi ça ça a changé ma
vie ce petit objet c'est incroyable
c'est ma première caméra HD et en fait
c'était mon père il il adorait faire des
espèces de films de famille je sais pas
il merci à cette passion étrange qu'il
avait en réalité mais tu sais il filmait
je sais pas les repas de famille les
trucs étaient toujours comme ça il
filmait il faisaient des zooms tu sais
sur les visages là comme dans les années
90 il filmait tout et tout donc il
s'était acheté ça pour pouvoir filmer et
et du coup bah quand il a vu que moi je
je m'intéressais aussi à faire des
vidéos il s'est dit oh [__] mais
attends c'est génial parce que moi aussi
c'est ce que je fais avec mes trucs de
famille et cetera donc tiens tiens mon
fils c'est la caméra que j'ai acheté
pour faire mes films de famille
maintenant elle est à toiable bah
franchement c'est exceptionnel on va
relancer la roue ah ouais carrément
j'avais
oublié tu quand tu veux PAF tu vises un
truc particulé là
ou
non celui-là je réfléchissais je dis
est-ce que je visis un truc c'est un
symbole email ou courrier
je te laisse découvrir ce qu'il y a
juste
derrière tu peux le lire ah mais ok
notification d'une exclusion de cours
c'est un mail qui provient de CPE lycée
Descartes le lycée où j'étais Anthony
madame j'ai le regret de vous informer
que votre enfant auch char Lucas élève
de la classe de Première ES2 a été exclu
d'un cours à la demande du professeur à
l'époque quand tu tu es à la fois lycéen
et à la fois youtubeur comment est-ce
que tu vis ce cette combinaison des deux
à l'époque je pense que j'aurais pu
concilier les deux mais que j'étais un
peu plus motivé par l'un que par l'autre
dem lequel donc on se demande lequel
donc forcément bah tu as tu es un ado tu
es plus tu es évidemment tu es galvanisé
par le fait de faire des vidéos jouer
partager tout ça puis en plus tu as des
retours de gens ça cré des interactions
sociales et tout et du coup bah les
cours qui étaiit pas j'avais des cours
que j'aimais bien en plus en vrai tu
vois au lycée genre les cours d'histoire
j'adorais ça il y a plein de trucs que
j'aimais bien mais bon j'aimais pas
autant ça que faire des vidéos quoi et
euh et forcément bah voilà ma mère
devait être très contente de se prendre
ce petit mail mail comme ça et tu as
arrêté tes études après le bac c'est un
truc du coup forcément qui est différent
du quotidien de pas mal de personnes de
pas avoir connu cette période là de je
sais pas de vie étudiante de soirées
étudiant de tout ce qui va de tout ce
qui va avec est-ce que c'est un regret
de pas avoir vécu ça est-ce que tu
aurais aimé le vivre je pense c'est pas
un regret en vrai mais ça a commencé à
l' à un moment quand des potes m'ont dit
frérot tu as tu as tu as rien vécu là tu
as tu as tu tu fais que de bosser bosser
bosser Tu gagnes bien ta vie tu prends
du plaisir dans ce que tu fais c'est
cool mais kiffe un peu la vie au-delà du
taf en gros Squeezie qui prenait trop de
place par rapport à Luca quoi j'ai aussi
eu beaucoup de chance de vivre ça quoi
ça c'est comment dire il y a plein
d'épreuves de de de que tu es censé
traverser dans ta jeunesse et dans ta
vie de jeune adulte que moi j'ai pas eu
à traverser parce que j'avais déjà un
taf je gagnais déjà bien ma vie j'étais
stable tu vois et ça change beaucoup de
choses je vois mes potes galérer leurs
études 2 ans plus tard j'ai des news de
lui il me dit en fait je change de voix
machin tu vois je me dis [__] c'est
des problèmes que j'ai pas que je peux
même pas concevoir j'ai une chance
énorme et donc je veux en être digne
donc je vais tout donner tout donner
tout donner tu vois c'est un peu ça que
je me disais ouais il y a un truc moi je
le sais parce que j'étais là donc tu as
assisté en 2021 du coup on part en
vacances on essaie de faire des vacances
classique enfin je sais pas comment don
là mais on on réserve des
Airbnb on prend des on prend le train on
va dans le sud à ce moment-là c'est ça
paraît bizarre dit comme ça mais c'est
l'une des premières fois que tu prends
des vacances la prère c'est ce que tu
dis cé cette envie de rattraper ce
tempsl et de vivre ce genre de ce genre
de chos je crois d'ailleurs qu'on a des
belles des belles photos dans la table
table
télé Bau de trip on a fait du du camping
ce qui était on a dormi aussi dans une
caisse parce que il y avait aucun
camping ou hôtel d'ouvert en fait des
trucs qui sont ce que des gens ce que
les gens vivent globalement tout le
temps dans leur vie tu vois mais qui
pour moi j'ai l'impression qu'on a vécu
un truc exceptionnel que personne n'a
vécu tu vois parce que j'ai vécu qu'une
fois donc à chaque fois que je parle de
ça aux gens je suis hyper mais tu te
rends compte F mec tu as juste fait un
camping et je fais ah ouais c'est vrai
tu bosses avec avec un peu de ta famille
aussi aujourd'hui ouais avec mon frère
tu veux dire ouais notamment tu bosses
oh il est là comment ça va ouais super
tu vas bien ça tuas bien oh là là le
frérot dans un contenu la dernière fois
qu'on a tourné ensemble c'était alibi
c'était derrière enfin c'était derrière
c'était pas exactement là mais c me j'
pas vu non je n'ai pas vu qu'il y avait
ça gars je viens de voir qu'il y a Ali
ici c'est exceptionnel ouais c'était ça
exactement bon Florent oui pardon on n'
pas fait du coup les les présentations
ah là voyeis c'était Hugo travers c plus
Hugo décrypt oui Florent déjà merci de
de de venir ici merci à
toi déjà première question que j'ai
envie de te poser comment est-ce qu'il
était vraiment Lucas quand il était
arrange pas arrangeinquiè tu es pas
obligé de dire toute la vérité
impeccable il avait déjà la même énergie
ça c'est sûr mais il la mettait pas de
la même manière quoi mais ouais c'était
c'était un enfant bah hyper actif en
tuétait hyper actif ouais complètement
complètement hyper actif qui était tout
le temps en train de faire 1000 trucs
est-ce que tu te souvens du moment où il
lance au début ce truc là et comment
est-ce que tu vois cette chaîne là
qu'est-ce que tu en vrai c'est un peu
flou moi j'ai des images de quand tu
étais quand tu était à la à la maison il
allit dans le fond de la baraque pour
jouer au jeu dans le bureau de mon père
dans le bureau de son de notre père
ouais et du coup il se filmait là-dedans
donc le tout début c'était bah un enfant
qui se filme quoi tuas pas vraent
davessus tu dis bah il fait son truc et
et derriurs quand il a lancé non en vrai
j'ai mis du temps à percuter pour être
honnête moi ça ça m'a pris pas mal de
temps mais comme tout le monde ce qui
est normal en fait à l'époque personne
comprenait vraiment ce Pass c'est qu'à
l'époque quand des créateurs de contenu
comme toi se lancent en 2011 il y a pas
de référentiel de ça peut aller jusque
là il y a pas de façon de se projeter tu
vois en 2011 je vais te dire le goal que
les youtubeurs avaient le goal qu'on
avait tous c'était pas gagner de
l'argent ou devenir connuou je sais pas
quoi c'était
d'avoir en fait sur Youtube c'était une
ancienne version de YouTube et dans
cette ancienne version de YouTube quand
tu étais Partenaire YouTube donc quand
ta chaîne était monétisée tu avais une
bannière en plus sur ta chaîne oui souv
sou et cette bannière tout le monde la
voulait du coup tu contactais des des
graphistes qui en fait étaient des
petits gars ind de de de de 14 15 ans en
autodidacte tu vois et tu les contactais
et tu faisais s'il te plaît Stéphane
fais-moi fais-moi ma bannière je je
passe Partenaire YouTube dans 2 semaines
je veux une bannière qu'enoie c'est un
peu ta comme ta voiture genre je sais
pas c'est gen c'est ta vitrine et et tu
pouvais customiser pour qu'il a des des
trucs clicables sur la bannière qui te
redirigeaient vers tes réseaux sociaux
et tout et et c'était c'est et ça
c'était le r le non mais anecdote avant
de lancer Hugo descrypt j'avais une
chaîne Youtube de jeux vidéo je sais
même pas si tu es au courant non c'est
vrai tu te faisais déjà défoncé sur ma
car ou pas non non alors non non déà
j'étais déjà extrêmement fort à l'époque
j'avais un niveau de fou et j'avais une
chaîne vidéo et je faisais des des des
du Minecraft et d'autres trucs ce que je
vous propose c'est qu'on bouge là-bas oh
non par faire un lib oh non ça nous met
dans un je sais pas pourquoi ça nous met
dans un état ce cou je te promets qu'on
seôle vraiment alib venir ok on va
bouger [__] mais c'est fou que j'ai
pas vu ce truc en vrai c'est hucinant
aprs c'est juste un coin sombre avec une
lumière on va
s'installer est-ce qu'un jour on verra
sans une tablette à non c'est partie de
M on le voit pas mais là j'ai un fil qui
relie la tblette à ma fait partie de ton
corps je donne quand même le conta ex
pour ceux qui n'ont jamais vu ce concept
là ça peut
arriver c'est un décor issu d'une tes
vidéos un tes concepts de vidéo alibi
qui permet de tester la complicité entre
deux personnes là on va le refaire mais
différemment ok c'est un texte à trou je
vais vous demander de compléter donc je
vais lire un texte à chaque fois il y
aura des trous vous devrez écrire ce qui
vous semble le plus juste dans le TR sur
exactement mais mais sur le sur l'
imagine on met jamais la même chose les
gens vont croire que cou sé son
montage il faut une complicité on veut
de la complicité ou rien ok je suis prêt
balance hier midi vous étiez invité à
manger chez la famille vous sonnez au
moment d'ouvrir la porte votre père voit
Lucas et l'appelle par son surnom
lorsqu'il était
enfant what ouais tu l'as évidemment que
je l'ai pas si tu crois que je mets 3 2
1 je savais qu'il allait faire ça bah
ouais bah il faut deux qui passe les
sais pourquoi parce queou il s'est dit
bon bah surnom il y en a pas mais je
vais mettre le surnom de base alors
Florent a mis Lulu mais moi j'avais ça
en tête aussi tu vois j'ai gagné
écoutez-moi bien écoutez-moi bien mon
père ne m'a jamais appelé Lulu de ma vie
il est 13h vous passez à table votre
père vous a préparé son plat
incontournable de c'est gagné c'est
gagné c'est gagné c'est gagné c'est
gagné c'est gagné c'estc par contre le
le le plat incontournable incontournable
il y a un minimum de complicité quand
même on est d'accord on est enfant je
sais pas comment on écrit le nom du j'ai
trop hâte de voir du coup non vas-y
arrête je sais pas comment après si on a
pas marqué la même chose c'est
incroyable c'est écoute-moi bien si on a
pas marqué la même chose je quitte ce
plateau et je ne tourne plus jamais avec
cet individu là là je le pardonnerai
jamais là je le pardonnerai jamais 3 2 1
c'est parti gratin de quoi
de non c'est pas possible frérot quand
on était petit c'était les COS qui
cordon bleu non c'est pas c'est quand on
était petit ça c'est quand on est grand
c'est les deux plat de il a fait évoluer
ça ver un grattin de
Macar avons-nous eu la même
enfance je grandis à tes côtés mais mec
est-ce que vous êtes vraiment frèrees
disnous s'il a TR je sais pas ce que je
fais là en fait là un doute là c'était
bien là avec les grands-parents c'était
vraiment bien mission était bien il y
avait plus de complicité ave les
grandsents ok ça j'en ai un il est très
subjectif mais du coup il est
intéressant depuis toujours le plus gros
défaut Luc est he le plus gros
défaut j'écris très mal je me rends
compte là on éc sur l'ardoise en on
écrit rarement tout court c'est vrai
mais allez-y le plus gros défaut de
Lucas oh mec la question qu'on attendait
pas et tu vois on est complice impulsif
et ma retour de complicité c'est une
thérapie en fait là c'est ça c'est
littéralement ce qui une thérapie juste
avec 15 caméras oui un peu Glock
finalement merci beaucoup on se
réinstalle
doit régler des choses c'est vrai il
faisit beaucoup il fais beaucoup de coqu
à l'épque où oui tu as raison tu as
raison Maisdon Florent merci beaucoup
merci d'être d'être venu ça fait plaisir
jouer à ce jeu ce je à ce jeu de
l'acomplicité incroyable monsur au
revoir
Monsieur Merci beaucoup Florent d'être
d'être venu ciao bisous mon frérot il y
a quelques guestes qui viennent comme ça
il en temps réel j'adore oui ça y est
c'est h au travers là c'est plus du tout
Hugo des CR ah je suis content on va
passer à la question suivante ça te va
et je t'invite à appuyer quand tu veux
et
paf la télé je crois que c'est celui-là
que je voulais et il y a une télé là-bas
qui vient de s'allumer si tu veux on
peut aller voir
non on y
on bon haut de décor pour ceux qui
mettre dans le canf ah non c'est se
mettre là alors on est dans un autre
décor on est décor de il y a quoi
derrière la porte il y a quoi derrière
la porte ce que je te propose de faire
tu as une télécommande ici c'est
d'appuyer quand tu veux sur le numéro 1
et j'appuie maintenant Bou je do
expliquer pourquoi vous êtes un génie
vous êtes un génie parce que votre
boulot consiste à vous filmer en train
de jouer à des jeux vidéos et à le
diffuser et les gens vous regardent
jouer et comme il y a de la pub vous
gagnez de l'argent ça je dois dire bravo
alors c'est devenu un métier donc en
2017 de regarder des jeux vidéos et de
les commenter est-ce que vous avez
essayé de vous filmer en faisant
d'autres trucs par exemple lire dormir
baiser ça marche
non on est en
2017 c'était il y a 6 ans eu déjà
qu'est-ce que tu ressens quand tu sors
de cette émission en
2017 en fait moi je me rends c'est
marrant je me rends pas compte de ce que
j'ai vécu ça veut dire je sors et je me
dis bon
ok ils sont allés un peu plus fort que
ce que je pensais mais tu sais j'avais
pas d'attente très positive quoi
naïvement en fait puis je me rendais pas
aussi non plus trop compte de ce que je
m'étais pris dans la gueule en fait je
sais pas j'étais dans un dénis j'étais
là OK puis c'est qu'un fois que c'est
sorti et que les gens eux se sont s'en
sont rendus compte avec le recul que moi
aussi je m'en suis rendu compte j'étais
en mode mais c'est vrai [__] c'est
vrai qu'en fait ils ont pas été très
gentils au final c'est c'est quoi à ce
moment-là ce qui est ce qui est reproché
dans dans cet extrait c'est une forme de
c'est une forme de mépris c'est une
forme d'incompréhension c'est les deux
faut faut aussi avoir du recul sur ce
qu'on fait évidemment que quand tu fais
des lives sur les jeux vidéos twitch et
que tu gagnes de l'argent comme ça bah
pour des tas de gens c'est hyper flou
disent mais attends du coup tu es juste
payé pour jouer et c'est un peu ça on
est un peu pay c'est plus complexe mais
oui c'est vrai que à la fin on est en
effet payé pour jouer ce qui est
révélateur c'est que c'est pas un cas
unique sais il y a eu natouche et On
n'est pas couché c'était horrible Mister
V pareil dans c était rien il s'est fait
déchirer enfin tu dis non là il y a là
il y a quand même une intention de
tourner en ridicule ou de nuir euh les
ambassadeurs un peu de ces nouveaux
médias et donc en fait quand tu te fous
de ma gueule comme ça en plateau en
réalité tu te fous de la gueule d'une
passion que des millions de gens ils ont
j'espère que dans dans 20 30 ans bah les
petits jeunes qui arriveront et qui font
des trucs qu'on comprend pas forcément
complètement et ben on au lieu de les
vanner et de les tourner en dérision on
on s'intéressera à eux tu vois on sera
vraiment curieux ou alors si on l' pas
bah juste on les invite pas évidemment
qu'il y a des différences entre YouTube
et la télévision ou d'autres médias on
en a parlé on les connaît ce qu'on voit
aussi c'est qu'il y a des points communs
des proximités des des des choses aussi
qui peuvent se se rapprocher comment
est-ce que tu vois l'évolution au fil du
temps de ces deux univers là de ces deux
mondes là je pense que en fait on fait
pas forcément des choses complètement
opposées la télé et nous je pense qu'il
y a beaucoup d'idées qu'on a en commun
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de thèmes
qu'on veut aborder beaucoup de
mécaniques qu'on qu'on aime et sur
Internet et à la télé je pense que ce
qui change c'est plus la manière de
raconter les histoires les codes de
divertissement utilisé par exemple en
télé tu as souvent un public qui fait ça
pour rien sur internet tu as souvent
absolument aucun public en télé le
montage il va être un peu plus lent sur
internet il va être un peu plus nerveux
en fait c'est juste deux directions
artistiques différentes il y a plein de
thèmes qu'on va aborder qui vont aussi
aborder quoi faut pas être je pense que
le monde de la télé il a plein de choses
à nous apprendre il est beaucoup plus
vieux que l'audiovisuel sur Internet
c'est sûr qu' on a plein de choses à
apprendre et à l'inverse je pense qu'on
a plein de choses aussi à leur apprendre
donc moi je trouveris je trouverais ça
cool en vrai qu'il a des qu' ait des
crossover et que et queil y ait des
choses qui se fassent dans ce sens ça te
va on va se réinstaller ouais avec
plaisir allez foryard foryard qu'est-ce
que c'est culte que sais pas c'est que
derrière ce rideau il y a le PER for il
va te poser une question non mais c'est
vrai que Ctait culte quoi franchement il
sont vachement avangardistes sur
beaucoup de choses on va relancer la
roue
allons-y c'est un sablier ahah est-ce
que tu as en tête ce qui se passe avec
ce sablier non si je te dis que tu as 60
secondes pour répondre ah c'est ça oui
ah je suis content de faire ça c'est
super ce sablier c'est un sablier de 60
secondes tu as 60 secondes pour répondre
à un maximum de questions par oui par
par non où est vraiment passé si tu
arrives pas à le à le dire ok et tu
serais vraiment très mauvais dans ce cas
arrête je ils font tout ça à chaque fois
et moi je suis mauvais si je le fais le
bâtard tu es prêt ou pas je suis prêt
près c'est parti est-ce que tu regrettes
parfois d'être youtubeur non un
imposteur avec DiCaprio et Brad Pitt
est-ce que c'est possible non tu as peur
d'avoir 30 ans non twitch c'est mieux
que
YouTube non l'argent fait-il le bonheur
euh
oui il y a des invités sur ta chaîne que
tu as trouvé ultra relou non tu
regrettes parfois ton pseudo non
tuécoutes time time en soirée non tu
crois au destin ouais inox il va réussir
à gravir les rest ouais si on fait un
Mario Kart tu me bas oui faux c'est faux
fa c'est faux tu as peur de l'avenir non
tu confierais ta voiture à villebrequin
non non non tu es déjà un boomer pour
TikTok non tu aimerais être invisible
parfois
ouais tu pourrais faire danser avec les
stars non tu penses être encore numéro 1
sur YouTube dans 2 ans j'en sais rien
Dofus c'est mieux que
valorent ah non tuestimes avoir réalisé
tous tes rêves ouais est-ce que tu
pourrais présenter une émission à la
télé B on sais pas de quoi il fait
demain mais et dernière question est-ce
que dans 10 ans tu sera encore youtubeur
on sait pas de quoi il fait demain c'est
dur les questions sur le futur je suis
désolé je suis obligé de tricher mais
c'est que la question sur laquelle tu as
le plus buggé c'est est-ce que Dofus
c'est mieux que valor c'est la question
il y a une mais mais c'est mon cœur il
est divisé en deux il y a une moitié
d'ofus et une moitié valorante c'est
deux jeux vidéos qui m'ont marqué
énormément et du coup c'est dur et pour
et c'est marrant ce débat l'argent fait
le bonheur on en parlait il y a pas
longtemps c'est une question évidemment
tu peux pas répondre juste oui ou non SR
mais je trouve que ça ça retire tous les
problèmes de répondre à tes besoins
primaires donc je t'es obligé de dire
oui je sais pas tu regardes pas le prix
quand tu fais tes courses ou des trucs
comme ça en fait tu peux pas oublier le
fait que c'est un confort de fou et que
ça contribue de malade à ton à ton
bonheur tuou s en vrai donc je contribue
tellement que moi je dirais oui ça fait
bonhe on relance la roue je t'invite à
appuer oh il il en reste il en reste oh
mais suis trop
content le tel c'est un téléphone oui
et mais attends il a plein de petit
opening
làir mais attends c'est quoi tout ça
pening là c'est
super on va
s'installer alors on est installé à
table oui hautre décor peut-être pour
tout le monde qui n'a pas le contexte
d'une autre autre vidéo ouais du pire
date euh là on n pas en date et on n pas
à table enfin on est à table on va pas
manger h par contre je t'invite à
répondre aux différentes questions qui
viennent de personnes qui à qui on a dit
que tu allais venir qui voulais te poser
une question ok la première si tu veux
ah c'est en audio c'est en ok on y va
coucou Lucas alors moi je voulais savoir
si tu considérais Cyprien comme ton
mentor merci de ta réponse grave ouais
grave Cyprien c'est quelqu'un que auprès
de qui j'ai évolué pendant des années et
quand j'étais très jeune j'avais 17 ans
et pour la petite histoire il m'a
peut-être qu' y a des gens qui savent
pas il m'avait contacté pour faire une
chaîne gaming avec lui cprien gaming
qu'on a fait pendant des années et qui
m'a apportter alors d'un côté oui
énormément de visibilité mais surtout de
l'autre ça m'a surtout apporté le fait
d'être au côté du mec de l'époque qui
est le plus fort sur Youtube et de loin
c'est mon mentor clairement c'est
clairement mon mentor et j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance d'ailleurs de de
d'avoir eu cette formation entre
guillemets privilégié sur et notre
métier et la vie globalement auprès de
lui tu vois c'était c'était incroyable
hello squee dis-moi ce que tu en penses
mais j'ai l'impression qu'en dehors de
Lena Natou et tres youtubeuses on a pas
trop de créatrices de contenu en France
comment tu l'expliques toi bonne
question bonne question c'est vrai qu'il
y a pas beaucoup de de créatrices de
contenu alors il y en a de plus en plus
en réalité mais c'est vrai que le
constat est qu'il y en a beaucoup moins
que que de youtubeurs quoi à quoi c'est
lié honnêtement je saurais pas
l'expliquer moi ma théorie c'est
qu'innet c'est construit pendant des
années autour du jeu vidéo et que le jeu
vidéo était un truc plus vu pour les
mecs tu vois les bons vieux clichés
alors je sais pas si c'est la cause de
ça à mon avis c'est beaucoup plus
profond que ça évidemment mais je pense
que ça a beaucoup joué quand même
là-dedans mais je suis content parce que
depuis quelques temps il y a quand même
pas mal de créatrices qui qui qui
raisonnent et qui font leur apparition
et qui sont super doués et c'est trop
chouette tu vois je pense je sais pas je
pense à magla je pense à bagera je pense
à
Ory sont des streameuses sont toutes des
streameuses et youtubeuses ouais donc ça
va mieux mais il faut que ça aille
encore mieux et encore plus vite je
trouve je pense qu'il y a un truc aussi
et souvent il doit y avoir une crainte
euh bah d'être exposé de ce que ça
implique surtout quand tu es une femme
et ça tu en as déjà parlé sur Youtube ou
sur les réseaux en général hein ce que
ça implique en terme d'exposition de bah
de retour de critique d'insulte même que
tu peux avoir tu as aussi un autre truc
c'est les youtubeurs qui du coup ne
veulent pas en inviter parce qu'ils
savent qu'il va y avoir des critiques à
à leur à leur égard et ils veulent pas
se sentir responsable de ça donc plutôt
de les inviter quand même et dire aux
gens qui critiquent bah qu'est-ce que
vous faites vous êtes con euh il
l'invite pas tout court enfin mais
écoute franchement on prend ce qu'on a
ça va mieux oui il faut que ça aille
plus vite en effet oui il faut que ça
faut queon évolue plus vite là-dessus
c'est c'est pas facile et je pense qu'on
a tous un rôle à jouer là-dedans quoi
voilà en espérant que ça ça continue à
se à se renforcer bah ouais bien sûr tu
on retourne a plaisir cétait un bon
dîner franchement c'était un super dîner
c'était excellent ouais c'était bien
assaisonné phrase grande qualité
laassaisonn l'assaisonnement surtout il
était le beurre là le beurre sur la
table était
incroyable
vas-y et c'est oh choqué un emoji choqué
ces dernières années on a le sentiment
qu'il y a eu tout un tas de choses qui
sont venu sur Youtube des choses
incroyables des choses plus discutables
des choses étonnantes en 60 secondes je
vais te lire le titre de plusieurs
vidéos sur YouTube à chaque fois tu dois
me dire si oui ou non selon toi ces
vidéos sur YouTube existe sur la
plateforme aujourd'hui wou il y a
tellement de tout et de rien c'est dur
ok pas é ok je su vê vas-y je suis pr 60
secondes c'est parti vas-y j'ai traversé
toute l'Amérique en allant tout droit
oui oui quelqu'un a fait je compte
jusqu'à 100000 oui oui quelqu'un l'a
fait j'écoute le réveil de l'iPhone
pendant 10h oui oui c'estm je transforme
ma maison en aquarium géant non si ça a
été fait quoi mais tout a été fait c'est
pas possible je kidnappe 20 personnes en
24 heures
non calmons-nous je me gifle pendant 24
heures en une vidéo non si ça a été quoi
Pr la Maison Blanche pour mes 30 ans non
non je reste 24 heures dans un frigo oui
non [__] pas mal je vais le prendre
autre vidéo qui qui est le plus fertile
concours what the fuck mec non Logan
Paul je donne 10 millions d'euros à un
inconnu dans la rue 100 million beaucoup
non non j'offre une île privée à un
abonné oui mis Beast je conduis un avion
de ligne sans aucune compétence oui non
ok j'ai payé un assassin pour tenter de
me tuer non et un dernier peut-être je
parcours toute la Russie en pas chassé
en P attends mais quoi le mec juste dit
à pied quoi c'est suffisant
pourquoi non non oh [__] mec mais
puisqu'on parle justement de vidéos à
faire sur Youtube qu'on parle de alors
là on voyait plutôt l'aspect surenchère
en vrai mais il y a un autre aspect qui
est par contre évident et on en a parlé
tout à l'heure c'est la monté en gamme à
tout point de vue en terme de concept de
production de machin des vidéos sur
YouTube j'était partant déjà qu'on
prenne un peu de temps pour en parler et
qu'on en parle aussi avec Théo
ah évidemment est là
ça va et toi tranquille la forme est-ce
que Lucas tu peux présenter Théo Tho Tho
thoorbonet réalisateur voilà et qui a
commencé sur internet avec le studio
Bagle enfin peut-être d'AES trucs avant
mais le truc majeur c'était studio bagel
et donc donc en fait c'était les
premières vidéos produites globalement
sur Internet en France que Tho réalisait
avec un ou deux autres réalisateurs
aussi mais il en a fait énormément et
qui était des sketchs en fait des
sketchs vraiment incroyables qu'on
marquait les esprits et la plateforme et
donc voilà Tho il a commencé comme ça et
puis du coup de fil en aiguille il a été
amené à réaliser des court-métrages pour
cypren gaming à l'époque c'est
courtmétrages dans lesquels j'étais du
coup puisque j'étais CPR gaming et c'est
comme ça qu'on s'est rencontré et
aujourd'hui c'est ton réalis il réalise
tous les bas tout ça tout ce qu'on voit
c'est c'est Tho c'est lui qui a réalisé
ça et alors réaliser peut-être je peux
spécifier c'est pas juste euh parce que
c'est un peu flou tous ces métiers en
vrai et encore plus quand il s'agit
d'Internet il conceptualisent les jeux
euh avec moi on écrit tout ensemble en
fait tout tout tout Squeezie tout ce
qu'on sort sur la chaîne c'est Tho qui
est dessus et qui écrit avec moi c'est
pas juste moi seul Théo comment est-ce
que tu vois cette tu asis sur les deux
trois dernières années bah clairement du
coup sur sur ta chaîne on a vu une une
montée en gamme plein de concepts qui
sont venus des moyens aussi importants
des studios même parfois de télé entre
guillemets comme celui-ci qui sont
utilisés pour faire des vidéos euh déjà
comment est-ce que tuexpliques cette
montée en gamme comment est-ce que tu
l'as vu toi ces deux trois dernières
années je pense qu'on avait envie comme
dit Lucas de de un peu faire évoluer ce
qu'on faisait quoi je pense que Lucas
aussi avait envie de sortir un peu de sa
chambre et de tenter des nouvelles
choses tu vois en fait de créer des
nouvelles choses à partir des
inspirations qu'on peut avoir que ça
soit à la télé dans d'autres pays sur
Internet dans d'autres pays dans ce
qu'on vit au quotidien tu vois là où
vous étiez tout à l'heure le pire date
c'est juste une idée qu'on a eu parce
que bah tout le monde vit des dates et
on se dit [__] ça serait marrant de
faire un jeu autour de ça je pense qu'on
kiffe avec Lucas aussi beaucoup faire
jouer des gens tu vois moi j'adore créer
des expériences immersives pour les gens
et tu vois de se dire que bah le temps
d'un date bah ils vont vivre un date toi
tu es fan de jeu aussi globalement même
tout ce qui est jeu télé il a une
culture jeuook est qui est exceptionnel
il connaitt des tas de trucs que moi je
connais pas il a beaucoup maté tout ce
qui se fait à la télé même en Europe tu
vois globalement aux US évidemment donc
en fait il a lui il a il a à la fois
cette culture Internet et télé que moi
j'ai pas trop tu vois on entend beaucoup
parler ces derniers mois de la la
question du risque de de Burnout des
créateurs de créateurs qui craquent sur
ce truccl ou qui qui n'arrivent pas à
gérer cette évolution au fil du temps
comment est-ce que vous vous le voyez
est-ce que vous le ressentez est-ce que
comment est-ce que vous voyez ça
aujourd'hui bah je pense qu'on le
ressent clairement enfin en fait j'ai
l'impression que tous les créateurs
passent par cette phase un peu de
d'autopression tu vois en fait la la
pression elle est pas c'est pas
nécessaire de se la mettre mais tu te la
mets forcément par défaut parce que tu
as personne audessus de toi donc en fait
c'est toi qui dois un peu c'est toi qui
dois le le truc quoi tu vois comme
n'importe quelle personne qui lance sa
boîte qui lance son qui lance en fait
c'est juste c'est juste la vie
d'entrepreneur quoi à partir du moment
où tu travailles à ton compte et que
c'est toi le seul responsable du contenu
que tu produis forcément ça met une
pression tu vois il faut arriver à la
gérer et ce qui est dur sur Youtube par
rapport à d'autres exemples comme tu CIS
des entreprises et tout c'est que tu as
un retour direct des gens quoi c'est que
les gens s'expriment instantanément donc
quand tu fais un truc qui est pas bien
tu sais que c'est pas bien tout de suite
quand tu fais un truc c'est bien bah on
est trop cont quand les gens disent que
ça c'est moins bien que ce qu'ils ont vu
sur une autre chaîne ma ça peut créer
aussi des effets ouais je pense qu'en
plus il y a ça énormément et le deuxième
truc je pense il y a beaucoup aussi de
créateurs qui ont peur de se faire oubli
qu'on peur d'un coup s'ils sont moins
présents donc s'ils s'imposent pas ce
fameux rythme diabolique que les gens
les oublient et passent à autre chose et
du coup ils ont peur de tu vois de tout
perdre en fait en étant moins actif donc
ils veulent être très actif sauf que bah
on reste des humains quoi au bout d'un
moment en vrai on en viient
naturellement du coup à ce sujet là
c'est la pression aussi qui peut être
associée à ça ça peut être un truc il
faut le dire qui peut être extrêmement
malsin toi Lucas comment est-ce que tu
gères ce truc est-ce que tu as
l'impression parfois de trop faire
est-ce que tu as l'impression de trouver
un équilibre au contraire pas du tout
c'est plus nos corps aujourd'hui qui
nous fixe la limite et encore on les
écoute pas assez on les écoute pas du
tout même que même pas du tout que nous
tu vois ce que je veux dire donc je si
en gros je dirais que c'est to much
ouais aujourd'hui ce qu'on fait c'est un
peu trop le rythme et qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à trouver un petit équilibre mais
mais faut pas le voir de manière
négative non plus tu vois parce que ça
génère quand même une espèce
d'adrénaline auquel on on est un peu
accro en c'est satisfaisant ben oui tu
peux c'est génial en fait et nous on a
une chance folle sur internet de pouvoir
avoir une idée et que un mois et demi
après quasiment elle existe tu vois il
un décor il est construit il y a des
caméras et que personne au-dessus de
nous ou de toi a pu nous dire non ça
vous faites pas ça c'est comme si ça
c'est comme ça on est dans une autonomie
qui est tellement jouissive Théo c'est
toi qu'on va entendre dans le
documentaire qui va sortir sur sur
pridéo tu es le fil rouge littéralement
parce que tu es la personne qui raconte
l'histoire de Lucas parce que bah de
fait ces dernières années tu a suivi
tout le parcours de Lucas et tout ce qu'
a tout ce qu'il y a derrière quoi je
sais pas suis le fil rouge mais en tout
cas j'ai la lourde de tâche de raconter
sa vie quoi pour ceux qui ça intéresse
de regarder ce doc vous vous le vivrez à
travers les yeux de Théo en fait j'ai
enviete de voir ça merci beaucoup thoci
mon merci à toi c'est trop cool à toutes
les gars bisous mon Tho on enchaîne oh
oui j'avais
oublié
vas-y la boule de cristal on a essayé
d'imaginer ton avenir dans 5 10 15 ans
et on a essayé d'imaginer notamment la
vidéo d'annonce que tu ferais pour
annoncer un changement de carrière ou un
changement de parcours ah ouais donc on
va voir des miniatures tu vas me dire je
mais c'est possible ou non de voir ça
sur ta chaîne YouTube dans 5 ou 10 ans
tu vas voir
ok première miniature et titre si tu
veux le lire oh WIS c'est bien elle est
super cette minia elle est pas mal j'ai
réalisé mon premier film d'horreur au
cinéma ce serait tu as dit 10 15 ans
ouais ouais ce serait possible ouais je
suis très fan de du cinéma d'horreur
alors aujourd'hui déclairement pas les
compétences que de décrire un scénario
viable ou de tourner ça et d'avoir des
skills pour pour que ça défonce donc
voilà je pense qu'il faut savoir rester
à sa place et et avoir un peu d'humilité
quand tu mets le pied dans un milieu
aussi ouf que le cinéma mais oui
j'aimerais bien un J si un jour je sens
que je je je suis prêt à ça et que je
j'ai du temps pour travailler dessus
énormément et progresser pourquoi pas
c'est vrai que ça me passionne
énormément le suivant qui est l'imposter
Emmanuel
Macron en une phrase est-ce que c'est
possible ou est-ce que c'est impossible
sur ta ch pense que les gens rêver
tellement c'est sensationnel genre what
the fuck tu as deux candidats de la
présidence qui qui jouent ensemble dans
un jeu mais bien sûr que non c'est pas
quelque chose que
tuimagines bah je pense c'est compliqué
de mêler des candidats à des élections
présidentielles à nos formats nous qui
touchont beaucoup de jeunes et toutfin
je je je sais pas moi je je Seris un peu
mal à l'aise au passage on voit vraiment
la ressemblance mais c'est vrai que il y
a une ressemblance avec avec Emmanuel
Macon la suivante je me présente à
l'élection présidentielle oui
oh que non les amis là là jeinvieussi ah
oui il y a un micro Hugo il y a YouTube
Hugo et ah là il y a pas d' pas un SP
l'ont flé non ça non c'est non vraiment
pas le le suivant je deviens animateur à
la TV entre parenthèse question pour un
champion euh franchement en fait je t'ai
dis la télé il y a moyen qu'un jour je
je sais pas de quoi il fait demain il y
a moyen que ça évolue de ouf et que je
sais pas on donne les armes pour faire
un contenu de malade qui coûte cher et
pour lequel j'ai on n' pas le budget
pour le produire sur Internet et c'est
dur de savoir de quoi il fait demain
donc il en reste une ou deux je crois je
deviens propriétaire d'une écurie de
Formule
1 si seulement là là il faut un peu de
moyens
financiers là là faut ouvrir une
cagnotte et que toute l'Europe contribue
non non bah ce serait exceptionnel mais
évidemment que non Mo a une équipe d'
sport ce qui est déjà ce qui est déjà un
bon début en terme de fantasque
mais bref et je sais pas si une si
j'arrête Youtube je prends ma retraite
bah oui tu pens ça arrivera un jour tu
penses qu'un jour il y aura une vidéo de
ce type là
ouais je pense je pense je pense que moi
je comment dire je pense qu'on est très
bon on est tous très bon dans quelque
chose pendant un un temps donné mais
tout es dans le un temps donné je pense
qu'au bout d'un moment tu es un peu
moins je sais pas tu es tu es tu as un
peu envie de vivre d'autres choses dans
ta vie peut-être un peu plus on en
parlit tout à l'heure tu as peut-être un
peu plus envie de te concentrer sur le
perso sur tes enfants sur ta famille sur
autre chose que le travail en tout cas
je je me le souhaite je me souhaite un
jour d'être moins branché travail et de
vivre un peu plus la vie comme tu es
censé la vivre globalement quoi et vivre
des des choses dans le perso et puis
voilà je pense que tout le monde fait
son temps dans ce qu'il fait et c'est
pas une mauvaise chose et puis il y aura
des nouveaux qui vont arriver qui seront
trois fois plus forts je les regarderai
je ferai ah qu'est-ce qu'ils ont for les
bâtards et ce sera cool pour terminer
parce que on a passé un beau moment
ensemble mais il y a un petit un petit
vocal qui vient de de quelque part je te
propose d'écouter hello mon Lucas
surprise je me suis dit que je pourrais
peut-être aider Hugo à décrypter
Squeezie enfin un petit peu moi je me
souviens quand tu faisais tes premières
vidéos à la maison dans des conditions
qui étaient pour terriblees mais tu
foisonnais d'idées et puis rien n'était
impossible quoi c'est tu pouvais tenter
n'importe quoi c'est toujours le même
moteur une idée et allez hop on y va je
crois que le truc c'est sans doute que
tu sais t'entourer de gens formidables
et qu'en plus tu les mets dans des
bonnes conditions dans tu les emmènes
dans ton aventure mais tu sais ce que je
trouve essentiel c'est que malgré le
succès tu as gardé tu as bien veillance
voilà Squeezie c'est finalement pas très
compliqué et moi Lucas je suis fier de
ce que tu fais et de ce que tu es et
pareil pour Florent j'ai de la chance
d'avoir deux gars formidables allez
bisous mes amours et merci
Hugo c'est une super off c'est une super
off mon père il vra c'est vra qu'il est
beau il pourit raconter des histoires il
a raison quand il dit que Squeezie c'est
pas si compliqué en vrai ouais c'est pas
si compliqué en fait en soi c'est comme
il dit mon père c'est juste des idées
une envie de créer des choses et de le
montrer aux gens et c'est aussi simple
que ça et il a aussi raison dans le fait
qu'il dit que chaque personne a eu son
importance là-dedans et je le disais
tout à l'heure sur ce truc de
bienveillance moi je pense que c'est les
gens qui m'ont rendu bienveillant je
pense qu'à la base je l'étais pas
j'étais très névrosé beaucoup de
complexe et cetera et que les gens m'ont
vraiment aidé à me construire et à et à
être plus serein merci Lucas céit trop
bien merci hein ça m'a aimu c'était beau
ce petit message ça m'a aimu c'était
trop bien va jouer à Mario carart m je
ramener ma switch on va se la mettre on
part sur Mario carart
merci mon c super je v pas te serer la
main je suis content qu'on est tourn em
bah ouais c'était un super moment avait
mon frère th mon père ramené des gens de
fou tu veux garder la miniature pense
que c'est très important c'est un cadeau
de Jan tu as vu que j''y tiens beaucoup
c'est marrant cette remarque sur les
yeux je m'étais jamais dit ça
allaitir une question de faire des gros
yeux pourquoi le tout est bon pour
générer du clic mais
oui
littéralement
tout c'est vrai vra ah oui ouais ah oui
vra
allez ça m'a PL de ouf frérot je me suis
régalé